[Música]
finalizó sin acuerdo a la reunión entre
el presidente Joe Daniel líder de la
cámara de representantes el republicano
Kevin mccarthy pese a ello el legislador
resaltó que fue un encuentro productivo
y que hubo avances en áreas contrarias
el personal de ambos equipos continuará
negociando para que el país no caiga en
impago el primero de junio Tenemos
reporte
en Guyana la policía informó que el
incendio en una escuela primaria que
dejó 19 menores fallecidos pudo haber
sido provocado a su vez el presidente
del país envió sus condolencias a las
familias y decretó tres días de luto
mientras la investigación continúa
en Argentina entró en circulación el
billete de 2000 pesos la denominación
más alta hasta la fecha se trata de una
nueva estrategia que busca combatir la
inflación en el país nuestro
corresponsal en Buenos Aires nos amplió
los detalles
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos damos inicio en
Estados Unidos porque no hubo acuerdo
pero sí avances tras la reunión entre el
presidente Joe biden y el presidente de
la cámara de representantes en
republicano Kevin mccarthy sobre el
techo de la deuda fue el tercer
encuentro entre los líderes y mccarthy
destacó que fue productivo y que se
avanzó en temas en los que difieren las
partes Así mismo Indicó que continuarán
las negociaciones entre los equipos
bipartidistas previamente Cristóbal
Vázquez corresponsal de France 24 nos
amplió los detalles
tras su tercera reunión para tratar de
alzar el límite de la deuda en Estados
Unidos
de comunicación tras reunirse con biden
en el salón oval dijo que el tono de
esta reunión había sido muy positivo
positividad es como resumiría esta
reunión de la presidente de la cámara de
representantes el republicano Kevin
mccarthy diciendo que él cree que aunque
la fecha límite para estar el límite de
la deuda sea el primero de junio y se
tenga que aprobar en el congreso todavía
hay tiempo para lograrlo descartó una
salida de corto tiempo es decir alzar
marginalmente el límite de la deuda para
ganar tiempo en una negociación
definitiva también descartó el tema del
recorte ven de defensa para poder llegar
a un acuerdo el defensa no se va a
cortar los gastos dijo él el presidente
de la cámara de representantes también
en lo que tiene que ver con los gastos
siguió insistiendo que la administración
de biden ha gastado cifras millonarias
desde que llegó a la casa blanca y que
precisamente eso es lo que quiere cortar
los republicanos el chorro en el gasto
Público de la administración de biden
volvió a Resaltar que no está de acuerdo
en aumentarle los impuestos a las
personas que ganen más de 400.000
dólares al año como lo ha venido
diciendo el presidente Joe biden y que
se necesitan más gastos para que la
economía de Estados Unidos esté más
sólida eso es lo que Argumenta el
republicano Kevin mccarthy para poder
llegar a un acuerdo sin embargo pues ya
hemos conocido que de parte de la
administración de biden lo que ellos
quieren es levantar este límite de la
deuda después de la pandemia teniendo en
cuenta la cantidad de gastos que tuvo
que incurrir el gobierno Y pues seguir
financiando el tema de la deuda
estudiantil y la producción la
generación de energía verde unos temas
que no quieren seguir financiando los
republicanos el pasado 10 de mayo el
gobernador del estado de Florida ronde
santis firmó un estricta ley contra la
inmigración irregular que entrará en
vigor el primero de julio la normativa
obliga a los empleadores a comprobar el
estatus migratorio de sus trabajadores y
establece cinco años de prisión o una
multa de 5000 dólares por persona cuando
alguien transporte una persona que
ingresó de forma irregular a territorio
estadounidense ampliamos los detalles en
el informe
en toda Florida los trabajadores
indocumentados Están preocupados por su
futuro el gobernador ronde santis firmó
lo que llamó el proyecto de ley contra
la inmigración ilegal más fuerte de la
nación para prohibir que los que no
tienen papeles acepten trabajos en el
estado a partir del primero de julio las
empresas con 25 o más empleados tendrán
que comprobar la situación legal de
todos los nuevos empleados mediante el
sistema federal y verify bajo amenazas
de fuertes multas Aunque la ley aún no
ha entrado en vigor ya está teniendo
repercusiones
ya se ha ido de este edificio
de todas las obras están guiñando todos
según el centro de estudios migration
institute de los 22 millones de
residentes de Florida
772 mil son indocumentados y si se les
eliminara de las nóminas la economía del
Estado podría sufrir una pérdida de casi
13.000 millones de dólares el estado
depende en gran medida de la mano de
obra inmigrante digan lo que digan
está probando activamente legislación
perjudicial que no resuelve nada que
daña nuestra economía que crea miedo e
incertidumbre en quienes solo quieren
que les dejen en paz pagar sus impuestos
y mantener a sus familias
algunos inmigrantes dicen que si no
pueden trabajar Se mudarán y encontrarán
trabajo en otro estado lo que supondrá
un golpe devastador para las empresas de
Florida
la policía de Guyana informó que el
incendio que dejó 19 niños fallecidos el
lunes habría sido provocado los hechos
ocurrieron en una escuela secundaria al
sur de Georgetown la capital del país y
seis menores más se encuentran en estado
crítico los bomberos explicaron que el
edificio estaba completamente en llamas
cuando llegaron al lugar el gobierno
decretó tres días de luto
la investigación inicial sugiere que el
incendio se inició minuciosamente como
ya se informó la investigación está en
curso
quiero decirle a todos los miembros de
la familia aquí presentes que
continuaremos estando a su lado y
apoyándolos Durante este momento muy muy
difícil
continúan los choques diplomáticos entre
Perú y México una comisión del Congreso
pidió al pleno que se declare persona no
un grata al presidente mexicano Andrés
Manuel López Obrador recordemos las
fuertes críticas del el gobierno de Dina
boluarte incluso a ella la calificó de
Usurpadora y se sigue negando a entregar
la presidencia pro tempore de la alianza
del Pacífico Francisco Zacarías
corresponsal de France 24 en Perú nos
explicó el porqué de la decisión del
Congreso y la reacción de López Obrador
para los congresistas de la comisión de
relaciones exteriores del parlamento de
este país resultan inaceptables las
palabras del presidente de México Andrés
Manuel López Obrador contra la
presidenta peruana Dina boluarte porque
señalan que está encargadas de
falsedades respecto al fallido golpe de
estado de Pedro castillo y en esa línea
sostienen que la actitud de López
Obrador viola el principio de no
injerencia y derecho internacional por
eso le declararon personas no grata y le
exigieron a la cancillería peruana que
impide el ingreso de Andrés Manuel López
Obrador al territorio peruano en esa
línea horas antes el mandatario mexicano
señaló que no comparte lo que piden los
legisladores peruanos pero señaló que le
parecería a él un orgullo ser declarado
no grato en Perú y además López Obrador
reiteró su digamos descontento porque
Pedro Castillo haya sido destituido y
también detenido por la justicia peruana
Argentina puso este lunes en circulación
un nuevo billete para combatir la
inflación se trata del de 2000 pesos el
de mayor denominación hasta el momento
en el país suramericano cuando las huida
de los precios superó el 108% interanual
consultamos antes con nuestro
corresponsal en Buenos Aires el valor de
la divisa en el mercado paralelo y
oficial Esto fue lo que nos dijo
me hubiera encantado haberles podido
Mostrar uno pero no pude hacerme con uno
de estos billetes nuevos de 2000 pesos
fui un cajero a sacar dinero a ver si
recibía uno pero no me dio ninguno De
hecho no encontré a nadie que hubiera
visto uno de los billetes físicamente y
en persona
están las autoridades comenzando a
distribuirlos dijeron así que me parece
que todavía es poca o ninguna de la
gente que ha podido tener uno en sus
manos es el billete de más alta
denominación ahora luego del de mil
pesos que era hasta hoy el de más alta
denominación pero no es mucho dinero
convertido al Dólar oficial serían unos
8 dólares con 50 convertido al Dólar
informal sería alrededor de 4 dólares
para que alcanzaría este billete hoy en
día bueno con la altísima inflación que
hay en Argentina para lo que alcance hoy
no va a ser lo mismo para lo que alcance
dentro de un mes hoy por ejemplo los
tomates en algunos lugares tan
especialmente caros y podrían llegar a
estar el kilo de tomates a 2000 pesos en
algunas verdulerías aproximadamente 10
litros del combustible de más alta
calidad saldrían también aproximadamente
estos dos mil pesos así que no es mucho
lo que se pueda comprar con este billete
de más alta denominación hoy en día en
Argentina es un billete conmemorativo
que además presenta elementos y figuras
relativas a la historia de la sanidad en
Argentina y que Recuerda la salida de la
pandemia aquí en el país así llegamos al
final de este informativo ustedes Les
agradecemos su sintonía
[Música]